okay
here we go
oh I'm gonna play this person first
so every game will be a Gambit or an
ultra aggressive opening
um
oh I'm not playing the other I am
oh that's strange
thank you Andrew gifting to Cole Allen
music
all right we're starting with a wing
gamut Wing gamut Sicilian it's a cool
line it's deflecting the the pawn away
from the center
trying to get some quick development on
the queen side
uh
I'm just gonna let black take
I insist on being down upon
opponent not having any of it
okay play this
wow I think I have to take back I really
tried to Gambit there
now we have something that resembles a
Karo Khan
um there should be two Bishop D3 first
and challenge the bishop
I still want to play aggressively
uh play this first in the night
G5 wow
so we'll play Knight C3
ideas of Knight B5 maybe also ideas of
Knight E2 just to hold on to the pawn
it's my opponent actually playing very
aggressively
so H4 is a controversial move I'm
allowing this ugly structure
but I'm envisioning a scenario
where
I kind of played this move
Knight G5 Bishop H6 Knight H7
that's crazy
I think I'll do that
trying to keep with the theme
of this stream
so the thing about the structure it
looks ugly it looks very weak but if my
king comes to H2 it's so so safe
I remember like watching some a niche
Geary lecture where he was explaining
this concept
okay using some
thank you
thank you bigger Eric Rosen oh thank you
tattoo Baggins
okay let's move
let's move defends both Pawns
door but doesn't defend the spawn
okay I'm gambling
uh
yeah I've
Queen B6 was very strong I was pinning a
lot of things
are just one important thing okay I win
back the pawn
my Knight's just chilling on H7
it's actually a really interesting
position
and just pieces are scattered
now that the center is more open like
g3s
a bit of a Target I have to watch out if
I ever play King H2
and the bishop stays on the diagonal
then each four will be undefended
but I think I still want to play King H2
because E5 was maybe coming E5 is maybe
still coming if I take I got forked
but E5 I have Queen I5
foreign
[Music]
and Knight will come back
idea 96.
I'm kind of just abandoning this Pawn
but if Queen B3 I have Rook B1
my queen does defend backwards
and now all of a sudden there's some
pressure point on B7
combine that with Knight E6 this looks
actually like pretty promising
I mean I'm down two pawns but
have a lot of energy with the pieces
so there's this move
opponent wants to draw
uh maybe later maybe never
yeah this king is so safe especially
compared to this King
Under Fire
kind of like the prospect of Queen
D7
hitting the Knight and pawn both of
which are undefended
this Pawn's pinned the bishop is also
pinned to the B7 Square
oh no my Rook
oh no box Queen
okay
just want a lot of material there
yeah this King can't really be touched
okay that was a nice game
um oh can people hear the move sounds
maybe it's a little bit quiet
should be audible though
okay that was a fun start so that
started as a wing Gambit
a cool metal game position
and pretty brutal attack in the later
middle game
okay audio is good that's good to hear
okay
um so more aggressive gambits I mean I
gotta at least try one Stafford right
it's African the time
um okay
this is my
way of insisting on Stafford
if we're not getting suffered
I'll play a reverse Evans Gambit
that's probably not a good idea but
it looks kind of interesting
sacking multiple bonds
actually just one Pawn
white could have taken here
so the whole idea behind gamuting for
one you're trying to I'm trying to put
my opponent on the back foot early
and then just trying to get some like
early momentum
accelerated development
um this position not sure how much
compensation there is
wow I take on Busan I can also take but
then takes and D4 is a great move
let's go
vamanus
I think I'll take it this way and
move back
expecting Knight takes
okay Bishop B7 is a move
Bishop G5 might be coming in Queen C7
it's very iffy
uh good move Queen C8 I want to play
this
Unleash the Beast
I think I still have D4
I might be winning C2
not sure if I want to take C2 but might
be one way to recover material
I don't think I want to takes E2
I didn't want to allow the trade because
the night is better staying on the board
at least for me
yeah that's a small issue
play H6
and we could be Trading
like
trading minor pieces and then trading
Queens
so I'm still down the pawn but I have
the bishop hair
and maybe still some King side attack
potential like Knight G4
and Bishop D6 may be coming
Bishops are strong in the center
this Pawn is weak though in the center I
can't take
because Knight takes I'd Fork the Knight
and Bishop
this might be five
oh good move
What's Happening Here
I want to take on each two there's 97 in
the end
huh
trying to exploit the knights
trying to win back the pawn I think I
just plundered though
okay opponent had neither five
okay now it's an end game
attacking B2
play rookie eight
oh no I'm getting forked I broke G5
check
hmm
go for this
turning this
ah
oh that's unfortunate
I got sold on time
the this this position is waiting for
vac I just pre-moved
I I didn't uh I didn't play the right
move there
uh I got a little bit too long
good game though
that's a sharp one I really I spent a
lot of time early on trying to fight
back
what to do
okay let's try and continue some
aggression I'll play scandi
maybe I'll play some gamut line here
welcome back I'm Berg hey Eric hope
you're doing well just had a suggestion
for a YouTube short series of your most
funny checkmates beginning with your
very first on poisson Checkmate all the
love I have to go through the clips
I have been posting more like short form
content
yeah this game I'm like
I'm usually the one who gambits but here
I I accepted the Gambit
but I'm still trying to play
aggressively this is actually paying off
really nicely
the C2 is going to fall or the queen
will fall or both
Queen D1 Knight C2 King E2 Queen D3
checkmates
uh it's a move
check
let's start with this ensuring there's
no Queen B5
foreign
will still be falling
uh
that's crazy that Bishop B5 is actually
a big threat
so let's play this
like if I took the Rook Bishop B5 takes
and white would have at least a draw if
not more
but this is looking good so I'm
attacking the queen
and very soon actually where does the
queen go Queen C4
yeah I'll probably move back to D4
attacking The Rook
is this
is trapping the queen
and the queen is trapped
weirdly enough
I mean the Knight can take
but I'll keep keep harassing the queen
Rook CA coming
no mercy here
calculating Bishop B4
play this first preparing Bishop B4
oh there's a cool mating idea
is it meeting though
it's really close Queen takes Queen
Knight D4
okay that move I missed
oops
I have this move
unleashing the attack against the queen
it's getting kind of murky though
I have this move
we probably should not have gone into
this
uh
um
play this
Queen H6 is coming
okay that's a nice gift
I could have been in a lot of trouble
there
I'm still in a little bit of time travel
okay I'll take the Rook first
come back here oops
okay there we go that was much closer
than it probably should have been
oh man good game coolest to my opponent
for fighting very violently
the King was very slippery
someone doused it in oil
okay
I miss Maiden one I'm sure there were
missed opportunities
um no berserking let's play E4
trying to have some more gambits and
aggressive openings
thank you statsko
playing Vin days
okay
I'm gonna play a line
yeah let's play this sign
uh E5 and then B4 this is a wing Gambit
against a French
uh pretty offbeats
the idea is similar to what I did
earlier against the Sicilian
um deflecting the pawn away from the
center
against the French there's
um more of a positional reason for this
is that once I play D4 it's much harder
for black to contest the center Pawns
but then the other reason for this line
is
um here I'm guaranteed Knights D6
and black is already in some trouble
because Knight D6 can't be stopped
really
now D4
I mean this move might be coming
thinking with Knight F5 I just moved
back
and then if A6 I play G4
because there's a pin
we might see Knight H4
but wherever then I move I move back to
D6
hey it's Ilya niznik
what'sabelia hope you're doing well
a very strong Grand Master in chat
Okay so
yeah I returned to D6
oh no black can take and then win my
pawn and Fork me
someone call an ambulance
yeah I've um fortunately I've watched uh
Levy's most recent video about how to
Checkmate in four moves
Levy had a video where um he was
explaining this very important concept
that Checkmate on F7
as well equipped for Knight takes G4
yeah this is a dream come true position
hey this is really one of the
better scenarios from a wing Gambit
against the French
the Box pieces are a little bit sad like
the bishop has one legal move and it
loses instantly
and B5 I take it
now it is a question what is white
threatening here
but probably just a matter of developing
maybe eventually like going for the pawn
storm
or maybe threatening to win on time
um F6 I really want to take it but
let's not lose a knight
Play Bishop D3 first
okay I'll play C4
this could get interesting if black
takes black will have three Center Pawns
oh
that move I forgot about but this
wait a minute
uh
I messed this up I think I messed this
up
maybe it's not so bad
might win on time
wait if I take I get forked
oh dear
how'd this happen
okay let's take and check
ah I want a castle but I still get four
play a whole game speaking in Pig Latin
okay
is okay a pig Latin word
um we'll just play King of London
I'll shamefully went on time
I forgot how to speak pig Latin oh dear
I'm I'm in trouble here don't check me
I used to be fluent
when I was a child
okay
back to tournaments
what would my name be in Pig Land
because I don't know how you handle
words that start with the vowels
my last name would be ozin Ray right
igpay
something
okay A little berserk I'll play E4
continuing to mix things up
Carol Khan
um
I'm trying to think of a fun Gambit to
play against this
let's play yeah let's play Knight F3 and
then after D5 D3
this will be similar to a Tennyson gab
at Knight G5
and there's some cool tricks with this
sign
um probably most common for black to
take
Black's not taking but I'm giving a
second chance
um
okay now it's tempting to take the pawn
if I take the pawn we trade Queens but I
think there's still some aggression
this is upon the E4 have some initiative
uh if I play this there's Knight G4
and meanwhile H6 is a threat
what to do
I just have to defend and
maybe be a little bit patient here
want to play F4
I'm gonna preserve F4
oh I berserked
oh
I have 28 seconds
okay
well now I have to play aggressively
because I can't have this drag on into
the end game
I'll start pre-moving
actually maybe G5 at some point
yeah let's orchestrate some attack
g1's a pretty Savory move
and so is H5
okay the attack is Raging
threatening E5 Maybe
so if takes takes
wait takes
what do I take with though
I think I want to take with Bishop
now here I take
like weirdly transposes
foreign
F6 this bishop is kind of sad
which makes me happy
I want to double up
don't think there's much black can do
about it
although this move is possible
oh
I've trapped the bishop on each seven I
have three attackers
Rook F7 I take the Rook
um how to do this
I should just go into the King Pawn
ending
okay seven seconds it's enough time to
win this
foreign
[Music]
not all kingpong endings are drawn
is black gonna try and
flag me
or maybe just flag themselves
okay and one on time
uh
okay it was good that I didn't get too
long time
30 months of oh no my queen oh yes and
I've loved every second of it oh thank
you Gary happy 30 months
okay nobody's working I'll play E4 again
and getting a nice mix of some
aggressive E4 openings
I'll play panziani it's not a Gambit but
it's aggressive
maybe there's some lines where I can
Gambit
like this line I'll let black take my
Pawn
oh okay this is a nice opening trap
once the night moves I play Queen A4
check and win the other night
black realizes that
and uh okay I'm I'm up material here
do some artificial castling
salutations
thank you for the salutations
happy nine months to Cassie
now we saw this theme in the French game
this uh Square in the poems territory
defended by a pong a really nice Outpost
Square for the knights
there's not much black and do about it
now in that previous game I like I
mishandled it and got a worse position
so it's important not to be like too
celebratory
still kind of the fight
but prospects are looking good
let's play
I mean I could take the knights
I don't think there's any reason to play
this move
hello to shawarma
okay now
again there's no real reason to take I
think I'll just like slowly improve
King is slightly happier on the light
Square
okay now I'll take
maybe this Knight can come to uh
a different Outpost Square
another feature of the position the C
file is the only open file
so maybe it makes sense to fight for
just have to make sure the queen doesn't
come to H2
they're threatening this
and King H7
[Music]
um
I gotta be careful
check
and this first
kind of walking into a pin
hmm
and black is fighting Queen G3 out of
Knight F3
defending attacking
obstructing the defense
thank you Gary walking into a pin ouch
yeah I walked out of the pin though
everything's okay now
it only hurt for a very brief moment
okay let's throw in the check
and take a pawn
now I'm threatening um discovery
still maybe go for it
or do I sign my queen
and queen sock almost works
I really want the sack and then this but
um I mean this is a simple enough line
take take
yeah let me trade everything
you're really trading a lot of things
hooray eat hooray
okay very very soon we can celebrate
wait there there okay this
it's close but
I'm getting the job done
what's happening after King
there's King D4 which is surprisingly
tricky
I would have just queened but uh
okay here we go
I think you are right
no stalemates
okay where's the funny mate
let me try angulate first
[Music]
I wanted to triangulate to get this meat
uh okay
the opposition means
my king and queen had opposition on the
black king
's a tournament
okay
31st Place wow the leader has 45.
I only have 16 points
so if I want to win the tournament I
really have to berserk like every game
wow thank you funky donkey gifting 10.
also thank you to people who I didn't
acknowledge sometimes these games
take up most of my attention
um I appreciate the supports
okay we have a king's Gambit Faulk your
counter gamut
this is an interesting line
Queen D4 I think I just taken Castle
it takes the Knight I have this I may
have had this although probably not
Queen H4 was still a threat
five
yeah probably a mistake to trade Queens
but
doesn't look too bad I'm still down the
pond but uh these ponds are weak
I take
I want to go after this Pawn
like Knight B4 is a one of the main
ideas or an ID for
foreign
both Pawns
this pawns attacked twice too
now H5 is a counter attack
I think we're just Trading
although it takes takes
tricky
a nice move
um
actually I take with a rook
takes takes check there
can get really tricky
I mean Knight G5 is coming E6 is a bit
tender but rookie won
don't think it's too hurtful
maybe he could have played this
play this
my Knight's pinned
and this is a fork
Eric
hey
foreign
A2
there we go
It's Tricky
oh oops
there we go
okay plenty of time
okay that took work
I got the job done
oh man
yeah that was a hard fall game
almost didn't make it towards the end
there very tricky Rook ending
so
13th 21 points berserk again
um I'll play E4 again
let's play A Smith Mora
okay I insist
okay let's take this
I'm out of the theory but this looks
playable
at some point I can play E6
well this is opening
uh Play Bishop G5
what a weird opening
Queen B6 maybe comes yeah
I'm just going to abandon the queen side
Pawns
I'm gameting the whole Queen side
Bishop B5
it's all about peace activity
the more pawns I lose the more open
vials I gain
this obstructs the queen so I win the
night
um
I mean G5 I take it
oh dear
I have
huh
usually Queen E5 in that line too
G5 Queen E5 is interesting
wait we need no the knight's pinned
never mind
Queen E5 is not interesting maybe Knight
no not an 85 either
yeah I think I'm obligated to sack there
okay I'm gonna sack my Rook too oh no
I didn't want a queen trade
I was trying something
that H5 is probably coming
in rookie three
at least time is dwindling for black
so I'm down the full Bishop
of this Castle
hmm
more pawns I lose the more open files I
gain
the theme of the game
I want to play G3 if I get the chance
Bishop e8s902
[Music]
what's happening
play this first
I think I'm winning back the piece
foreign
yeah we're just simplifying
no I'm expecting Bishop A5 there
Lights On The Run
oh I made a queen it didn't really help
though
uh good game
oh that was a crazy game
okay still a lot of time left
two losses so far
leader has 49 points
hasn't lost a game
yeah the opening looks good at first but
things got kind of out of control I mean
I saw a lot of things that game and then
black sacked back and got the better
ending
um yeah let's go for scandi the one time
I played scandi my opponent played a
Tennyson
of okay I'll play E5
maybe reverse Danish
Bishop E3
I mean they're asking for D4 but
let me try and keep a position somewhat
open
F3
okay there's no time to be confused I
just have to
follow principles
yeah I'm going for a triangle formation
but
uh do I just sack
I think I just sack here
okay
this is already kind of backfiring what
to do
thank you Erdos oh no my colleague broke
my old Rose no oh no one call an
ambulance
I need immediate
medical help for your mug
hey we're getting the same idea again
I'm going to get my octopus Knights
octopus on E3
threading a fork two
I mean Rook C1 is likely
this this move has a few ideas to it
uh for one
it prevents Knight F5 I mean 94 is
coming
uh
Bishop G7
okay YK back the piece
no F5 coming
okay this should be good
my Knight's almost trapped but not quite
uh Knight C4 may be coming
Knight C4 E5 E4
uh how to do this
I'll bring the king in
what a position
I want to play F3 Bishop H4 and F2
checkmate
Simple Plan
hitting the Rook
I think you will
uh
let's still go for this
allowing the sack but then I'll win the
rook and the end
ooh
wait I'm not meeting
actually far from simple
should have taken the Rook
okay the bishop is locked in
okay
I got low on time there
GG
39 minutes left
a lot of Headway to me
so this blitzack
looks like drew a few games
still on the streak
okay
I want to be competitive in the
tournaments
uh okay
let's play uh Goring gambits which
started as an England and now we're
actually transposing into ponziani
a lot of different opening
transpositions there
thank you backwards popcorn
yeah so this is a position in ponziani
that I've had probably a good number of
times before
um play rookie one
just aligning with the King
the F6 was probably not a great move
for reasons that we'll see soon
D5
yeah this is a big headache for black
uh any meeting ideas maybe this move
so if it takes what's made into
threatening made into
a pretty bad position for black the king
can Castle Bishop's pinned pieces are
kind of in the way
uh let's check and mate
okay that was nice
that's why it's nice to know a variety
of openings because it started as D4 but
I went into a line in ponziani
okay
trying to rebound
13th Place
playing just tonight
I still want my first stop for this
tournament
are we going to see it no we're not
yeah it's hard to Gambit against the
sign
um
maybe F5
and a five and then Bishop C5
as
I'm kind of just making things up but
this looks
looks to be on the more aggressive side
Bishop E6
[Music]
um
that's a good move I think I have to
take
with the d-pawn
take with F Pawn
there there there
it's playable
Queen D7
I was expecting Knight G5
um
I had the option of taking but I'd
rather keep this bishop
okay the lights hanging I think the
queen has to move back
but that was probably an interesting
decision because my dark stories are
weak
what to do need this
and you have 97
I mean this looks like a very strong
configuration but once Knight D7 happens
it could very quickly crumble
long-term or maybe like medium term F2
is going to be
a Target
especially once this bishop goes away
like every single piece
these these pieces have potential to hit
F2
I like coming to G4 triple battery
action
even E3 could happen
start with the Rook F5
um
foreign
S I wanted to make Knight F3 work
take
Queen F6 first
so I'm threatening 903 to win the queen
we could trade
okay opponent misses it
so this is a discovered Fork
okay
so no staffers yet top 10 32 points
oh bloodstuck has had the first loss of
uh the tournament
but they've played it looks like they've
played more games than anyone else
so I'm trying to like not only play
games but win quickly
I want to play this um B4 Gambit
a B4 gamut declined
D4 happens
and queen is still a Target
and maybe G4 coming
I'm not holding back here
wow
play this
and Knight D5 taken bishopath three
assuming Queen takes
Pawn takes
you have to be a little bit more patient
I mean it's move 14 black has everything
in the back rank
I want to orchestrate some attack
got four
Queen E2 first
reinforcing
I'm not going to go after this Pawn
F6 is likely coming or not
so there's a cool idea to play
start with Bishop E1
ideas to play G5 take Queen H5 Rook H3
get some mating attack
they have G6 then I swarm the h-pong
yeah this looks very strong
and there's only so much black can do to
defend
there's 93 check King F3
Queen C2 defends H7 but doesn't defend
each eight
if F5 I played G6
take away the F7 square or Cafe that I
made
hey it's I'm a cola
oh that move I didn't see
I do appreciate the raid
um welcome everyone
uh wow so if I play this takes
I don't have time to calculate though
let's take this
if you're just joining we have a really
crazy position here
um I went all out for the attack
and now it's complicated
shout out to imacola
hope you had a nice stream
okay this was amazing
what a game
oh
yeah no time to waste between games it's
important to get in as many games as
possible I'm 20 points behind the leader
and they're higher rated than me too so
it's a lot to make up
um berserk still waiting for the first
stopper
are we gonna have it
okay we'll have a four nights there's
ways to play aggressively against this
this is an interesting line it's called
the Schmid defense
[Music]
um
it's not bad for Blitz confuses a lot of
people
D5 here
thank you infinitum
although
yeah we're trading a lot
but I'm up upon now
a two maybe under attack
do I want to take it to probably not
I'll just complete development
mm-hmm
a five
allowing Rook D4
okay I'll just Castle
threading F4 now
I'm not sure which what each four did
there
or maybe white wanted to move the rook
and not allow Bishop H2
yeah still looking at this this move but
don't think it leads to much
take their their
let's play E5 first now I'm threatening
to take
it was B3 and then A4 or B3 Bishop A3
first
[Music]
okay
C4 is coming
there's a funny line C4 Bishop F7 take
and then Rook E8
might actually win material
I'm not sure if white can actually take
the pawn
I'm in time to now defend threading this
uh
nice move
um play this
this could be close
foreign
's going to play here though like Rook
G7 King f8
okay
yeah this is winning
oh man these games aren't easy if 42
points in third place playing budash
I'll play E4 again
uh Lo-Fi Knight C3 Sicilian now the
Gambit but uh an aggressive opening
a Grand Prix attack
I mean this move's possible this move is
looking possible
actually like black is already in big
trouble here
okay let's take
the knights pinned
Queen D4
Queen D4 I take take and then take
I'm winning The Rook or meeting
okay up a piece
play D3 first
should be a simple conversion
oh
oh let's be careful I want to play Queen
E3 to get to Checkmate but I would walk
into Bishop D4
okay now there's no more pin and this is
pretty much Unstoppable
like G5 a typical pattern
okay
now 18 move win in second place
still kind of far behind the leader
um haven't played them yet actually
human brain
let's stay with the same opening as a
previous game
it worked out really well
like Bishop C4
or um
Bishop before is after Knight D4
there we go
I like this opening for fast chess
because the plans are very simple
foreign
first
an interesting idea of pushing apong
I still want to establish a knight on A4
it's a little bit more of a positional
idea
but then
yeah very soon going for the attack
maybe I should have started with that
five
let's block my place
is it equally as difficult as a GM Norm
um
it's
getting GM Norms are a lot more
difficult than I am norms
because there's a higher threshold in
terms of like results and performance
rating
um I got my IM Norms over the course of
five years
or no four years
got my first I am Norm in Brazil in
2011.
at the world u18 championships
and then got my second one
maybe in 20
I forgot what year 2013
2014.
got my third one in 2015.
so it requires um
it was I am
requires like 24.50 performance rating
I have to be careful here
and this Pawn diamond
wants to hurt me
yeah these light swears are very tender
but I have some attack
there's actually a crazy position
[Music]
like there's about four first
oh no my Bishop
what's happening
The Rook can defend
foreign
okay
okay I was very fortunate there
I mean felt very closely I think maybe
myself
okay
uh ooh fighting back
okay 19 minutes left
I'll go for a Budapest
yeah Budapest Gambit oops
my mouth slipped
oh what is this I'll play F5
okay this is a new
novelty in The Budapest a sacking a
night
so early
if I think G5 Maybe
[Music]
yeah yeah
okay
this is something
I mean I'm down a piece
Queen B5 would have crossed me there
hmm
not what I want
got this option
weird tactics here
I'll still be down the piece
um
okay weird things are happening this is
what I want
what I really really want
to take
let's move
what's happening so if takes I pin
if takes I take back
so now I'm I'm of a pawn I don't know
how that happened
what just happened
about to win another Pawn I have the
bishop pair
now I'm pinning The Rook
or the turnaround
still not on time
okay we're trading everything
what a game
where's my mate
there's my mates okay the game
oh I was insane
I mean I've that was the opening where I
plundered a piece on move three
if I Mouse lived the new and improved
Budapest Gambit
undefeated without opening
okay this player beat me before
let's play um
not a Gambit but okay I tried to Candice
this is a benoni Dutch
and so dubious opening but actually I
played this opening to get my final I am
Norm
2015 Philly open
I am with black
uh I think this is a move
thank you
I went through a phase playing this and
like studying the lines
we're gonna get a pretty abstract
position here
this is a move behind this
yeah I'm just going for the fiend cattle
hmm
I remember some idea takes and then D5
and pre-move that
wow
so I am down the pond but
I have an interesting Pawn Center
can I not defend this thing
I can't defend that I have to move it
and check
yeah
oh dear
some trouble
could actually be a lot of trouble
check
scared of Bishop C4
yeah because Knight D5 95 a queen D6
though
okay Sprites attacked
well the position
[Music]
really crazy position
I have this move
and the Pawn's still defended by the
bishop I want to play this
it's a fork
it's artificial Castle
attack the bishop
okay things are under control
still a little bit down on time but
no that's Checkmate okay what a game oh
what a crazy game
very abstract game
okay massive berserking streak I'm one
point behind the leader
playing Bondo the coach
play E4
and keep playing aggressive openings
let's play
do I want to play
four pawns attack
or pawns attack
G5 what is G5
someone's block playing aggressively too
um
play D5 idea E6
okay I really don't know about this
looks good though with a king here
E5 may be coming
E5 I take
oops Yeah Knight G5 coming
we're seeing this theme again and again
in my games
the night accessing a square in the
Pawn's territory defended by my pong
yeah this just looks really good now
I feel like this tournament my games
have just gotten crazier and crazier and
crazier especially those last two it's
absolute insanity
this game is crazy in a good way
of Vox position a little bit
questionable
this is just really nice piece Harmony
for lights
yeah if black socks I fork in the end
maybe I should have included Knight G5
oh
fancy
let's take that
this Square looks awfully juicy
but I want to start with Bishop check
and then
uh Bishop at five
try and trap the queen or just win the
queen
the only legal move
okay I have to get the final piece into
the game
there's later ideas of sacking and
pushing so The Rook can play a role
as a great Gotham chess would say The
Rook
the other Rook
I wish I could say it with as much
enthusiasm as him
okay
that was a nice game
did I LeapFrog hey I LeapFrog okay
but yeah second place is is on the
streak
uh
play D4
uh let's go back to this
this has served me well so far I'll play
D4
so when I have six Bishop B5 is a
interesting line
ideas if Knight C6 I just take it if A6
I play E5
um I think I'm supposed to take here in
Bishop F4 and just castle with check
and still get some attack against the
king
and Bishop G5 coming but then maybe E5
okay defending first
oh maybe I could have played this move
never mind
play this move
but then
the A3 first
yeah this game it's a little bit more
positional I tried to play an aggressive
opening
still trying to play aggressively E5
coming
maybe uh like Bishop C4 B3 ooh
play this
some cases each word concedes G4 but
I have this move
so I'm threatening to take and win
material
um
foreign
the problem is for black the Rooks are
not connected
of this move
G for the right moment
maybe Rook D4
be on my radar
um A5
c5's coming
okay that makes life a lot easier
but it's gonna still take a lot of
milking
like patience is key
speed is also key
hmm
ideals to bring the king to F6
or D6
or back to F4
okay I'm talking about
okay now the idea is to Checkmate on d8
the mission almost accomplished
Bishop D7 I win The Rook
yeah this is winning but Brooke
oh there's no stale Matrix okay
one more game maybe
let's go okay creating a cushion
big berserk streak
72 points I don't think
anyone's catching me at this point
but I'll try and find this strong one
final game one final aggressive Gambit
type opening I'm feeling a soul of in
Gambit
haven't played in the Sullivan
uh Knight F3
play this first
okay this isn't really a Gambit but
maybe it's something
okay I'm playing aggressively here we go
uh C6
A5
yeah this is something
yeah this game might not count for the
tournament
Uh something's coming to D3
although White's not threatening to take
as I take back and fork
this awkward position for lights
I'm threatening maybe to take on E2
with the Rook
G5
G5 there there
and this first
just applying more pressure
I really want to take
this first
Subway Prime
uh that's that's how looks like you
figured it out
uh let's play this
wait I gotta I gotta Focus
running a little bit low on time here
and night is kind of stuck
almost ready to take it
trying to clamp down
it's not simple
foreign
[Music]
that's still tricky with the time
situation
oh yeah yeah
everything's still defended
now just Trading
not easy
Knights defend everything
foreign
oh I want to finish the tournaments
oh man that game didn't count for the
tournaments but uh
I'll have to show some speed there
[Music]
wow GG Jesus
got some more confetti
that was fun I hope people enjoyed that
oh one more thing if this goes on
YouTube
shout out to people watching in the
future on YouTube
uh let me know your favorite game from
the tournaments
uh I'll time stamp all the all the games
in the video description
had some really crazy ones